دائما بدعي لها بالرحمه هيك والحمد لله
يعني دائما بدعي لها انها تكون زوجتي في
الجنه ما بدي شيء من الدنيا بس تكون زوجتي
في الد
[موسيقى]
بس محمد سعيد حبيب 21 خطيبتي وعلتي تستشهد
27 10 كمان هي وعلت
تسنيم كنت كنت ادلع اقول لها سنه قعدنا
اربعه اشهر بالضبط يعني هي انا خطبت كان
كاتب
كتابي في
266 استشهدت في 27 ع لما استشهدت يعني في
الليل تقريبا على الساعه حده اللي انا
فزيت هيك في الليل قلبي ن جزني قال لي في
شيء ما نمت طول الليل يعني في شيء خلاص
قلبي نا جزني في شيء ضليتني استنى بعت لها
رساله قلت لي يمكن نايمه بعت لها رساله
ابعت ابعت ارن احاول ارن على
الفاضي لحد ما صالت الساعه 7:00 قلت جيت
في شي لانه هي قاعد على الساعه 6 6 ونص
ترن عليا صارت سبعه ما رنتش قلت في شي
خلاص في شيء بعديها قلت لمض ارح افطر عند
اخويا هذا الا استشهد لانه كنت ابات عنده
وليلتها يعني بتت عند امي
رحت قلت دفتر عند اخويا رحت عند اخويا عد
بيت الدرج كان في بسكليت اخذته رحت على
الدار اللي هم قاعدين فيها لما رحت على
الدار اللي هم كانوا قاعدين فيها اطلعت
لقيتها مشش دار اربع دور حواليها مع الدار
هي نازله بسال الناس بقول لهم انا في شارع
اللي بيقولوا لي اه قلت بعوض الله بقولهم
طب مين طلع قالوا لي طلعت يعني هي وابوها
وكلها هي عيلتها رحت على طول يعني عند امي
وحضنتها وقلت لها واحد انين تلاه وبعثت
واحد لاخويا حبيب الله يرحمه وقلت له تعال
معايا واحنا على الشف عاد كان في لنا
مصابين في الشفا عاد رحنا على الشفا كلمت
اخويا برض اللي في الشفا قلت له واحد انين
تلاه ويلا ورحنا على الثلاجات وقلت لهم
وينها قالوا لي هيها رحت
شفتها قطعت تذكره اللي هي عشان تاخذ الجس
الشهيده وتحط على
التكفين اخذت الورقه وكل شيء وكفنها
وشفتها لما شفتها في التكفين عاد انا اكثر
شيء يعني كنت يعني اقول لها امسك الاخد من
هنا هيك اقول لها يا اخ دول احلى اح احلى
خدود يعني امسكهم يعني كل ما اشوفها امسك
لها كنت
خدودها مسكت لها خدودها هيك
وودعتها
واخدتها بعديه حطيناها في الشحن وبعديه
وديناها على المقبره في المقبره شلت انا
انا واخويا الله يرحمه شلت انا واخويا
الله
يرحمه وديناها حطيتها في القبر ماخليتش
حدا يطم عليها انا اللي طميت عليها لحالي
يعني ما خليتش حدا يحط عليها رمل غير
انا بعديه بكم من يوم يعني قلت خلاص يعني
سبتها لان انا مش قادر استحمل ان اضلني
واقف يعني سعيتها قلت اخويا خليك واعرف
وين علامه
القبر قال لي ماشي بعديه بكم من يوم اللي
هو اخويا استشهد ومش عارف وين القبر بعد
اخويا استشهد رحت اني ادور على القبر
تبعها وين ما
عرفتش واخر فتره لها قالت لي ايه اذا صلي
شيء اه بدك تتجوز يعني علي وهيك لوصل لي
شيء يعني قلت لها لقيت في واحد يستغني عن
قلبه كنت يعني احبها لدرجه مش طبيعيه
يعني قديش بدي اوصف لك قديش كنت
احبها فيش فيش يعني اي حاجه ان تخليني ان
اقدر اوصفها
عيطت بنزل كل ف البحر بقعد لحالي هيك بعيط
لي شويه ورجع تاني بكمل
[موسيقى]
شغلي بحلم في غزه فيش حلم الاحلام كلها
راحت دائما بدعيلها بالرحمه هيك والحمد
لله يعني دائما بدعيلها انها تكون زوجتي
في
الجنه بديش شي من الدنيا بس تكون زوجتي في
بس
[موسيقى]
c